hey guys this is dense defender I think
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is a review of Godzilla the 2014 version
because there's been so many there was a
1998 version that roland emmerich no
other people like oh you forgot to
mention the two thousand versions but
that was only in the Japanese yeah
police yeah but anyway so this is gareth
edwards yeah pretty new director he'd
done one kind of monsters yeah any
feature before and and so overall
thoughts I enjoyed it I liked it there
are you know some problems with it in
terms of like not seen as much as you
want to see but overall I enjoyed my
experience is a lot of great visual
effects yeah a lot of good action at the
end we're gonna give our overall
thoughts positive negatives or then
great and then we'll give our spoilers
at the end so we won't talk about
anything that's a total spoiler aim but
we can say this personally I think the
thing that people complain about the
most was there wasn't enough Godzilla
yeah like even just now you watched it
again i watched kind of part of it i've
seen it two and a half times right I
heard the people just now coming out of
the theater I wish there was more fights
I wish there was more guys yeah so what
are you thoughts see for all those
reasons I that's why I loved it but
Gareth Edwards I he was following
Spielberg and the whole jaws kind of
wave construct nalgonas this is not
going to be a classic like jaws but I
like that he hid the monster for a while
you had to one even though we know what
Godzilla was like we've seen the
trailers I still like not seeing him for
about 30 to 40 you know 40 minutes or so
as close to almost an hour long but I
put all those reasons that some people
complained I actually like that for me
no guy these are two different movies
you know I know you look Pacific Rim I
enjoyed Pacific Rim I don't think I
loved it as much as you did I prefer
this kind of movie more than Civic we're
more than seen everything at once even
though it's a different kind of movie I
liked how he hid Godzilla for a while
yeah there's some good suspense and
there were some teasing i think he just
did it too much too much because there
were some great moments yeah but
then he just kept doing it over and over
and over again yeah and waited basically
until the end to give us what we wanted
which was what why I still like Pacific
Rim better okay there are things that
are that are Godzilla does better
there's you know better story better
acting all that stuff but Pacific room
kind of knew what it was it was just
having fun they just dated yeah and and
you know in Pacific Rim you had like a
bunch of fights in the beginning in the
middle there's two fights in the middle
and the end this one that kind of saved
most of everything towards that and what
it was it did deliver though oh yeah and
alert yeah the end the ending the action
sequence Godzilla had his moment to
shine it was special effects are great
yeah oh yeah let's talk about the pauses
the visual effects were great I think
the scimitars fee was really cool
there's some cool looking shots there
have been complaints from other people
like he's you know stole shots from
Spielberg stole shots from Ridley Scott
and stuff like that bad people to steal
from if you're gonna steal I mean
Tarantino borrows Frankie was a Scorsese
that he and my whole lot like borrowings
it's it's a flat form of flattery I
don't think he's being cheap or not
being creative I mean he's good people
to steal from yeah and I think he stole
shots that are borrowed or Oh moshes
sure for certain shots but it wasn't
like for like a whole scene wasn't like
put together from someone else's so it
wasn't like they like duplicate he
didn't duplicate another movie he just
okay here's a cool shot that all use
also on talk about I love the sound this
side called sound engineering like the
sound mixing yeah there's a I'll just
say there's a senior a train where you
know railroad track where you hear the
these are they call them the these of
the mood to Muto's yeah like it's like
it sounds like this like the vibrations
and the Reaver whoever they however they
created that was awesome i love the the
sounds all the monsters made Godzilla's
roar is awesome yeah and the roars
really lay horrible it like you know
it's so cool I love that yeah and then
you know we had you know a bryan
cranston's in elizabeth olsen aaron
taylor-johnson yes yeah big ass yeah so
uh Konami yeah yeah gogeta yeah the one
that's really complain some people had
that there's not enough Japanese people
or Asian people but I mean Ken Watanabe
as holding it down I mean he did a good
job really likely the kind semi he was
like a cookie scientist but he did have
yours this wide-eyed look like and they
would drop the lines here let them fight
listen but yeah and stuff like and what
are some other positive stuff that you
liked about um I think you said Bryan
Cranston's performance actually uh and
then I like how they they bounced around
I mean it's not spoil anything we see
different locales Hawaii lil japan
little america little san francisco
obvious is what you seen all the posters
and everything so I mean movie moves a
little bit it has a little geography to
it and just the way they portray
Godzilla like the way look some people
other design of him is correct right
some people say he's a little fat but
he's supposed to be built like an
offensive lineman he's not going to be
he's not lean and mean he's a big dude I
mean that's what Godzilla is I love the
design all the creatures had just just
great designs I thought I mean look
feels look great too so great yeah I
mean just a little pretty creative with
everything the way they there's an
opening again that's boiling with just
in the opening credits they kind of like
those old footage you know from
classified files and the way they shot
that was really creative and unique and
I thought it all added a great sense of
atmosphere out to the movie well that's
what I think Gareth Edwards did the best
was the atmosphere and just kind of like
the way he tied in to to make the world
was obviously it's not a realistic movie
no but he made it try to be as realistic
as possible he tied in some news footage
right yeah you know in just the shots to
like a lot of wide shots that we show
you know like let's say all these cars
leaving the city yeah or just the
monsters fighting in the background kind
of gave like a point of view from the
human side there'd be a lot of shots
where he pan from like humans on the on
the on the ground level he'll hand up
yup to the monsters or heap and down
from the monsters to the people running
or people doing whatever so I kind of
gave you that that scale size for all
the monsters and I liked how um you know
in the the scenes when you would see
some monsters like there's some quick
cuts you know you see a little
then he'd cut away like I like he never
against I'm complaining about not seeing
enough but he never he really waited
till the end to give you the full you
know effect to see everything in its
grandeur I mean he really just kind of
held everything back which I liked okay
I mean the negatives I've going to the
negatives I like Aaron taylor-johnson I
like him is kickass a little Olson from
what I've seen her in you know she's
fine I just their story didn't really
interest me I thought Bryan Cranston was
a lot better couldn't want to nabi i
thought was underused he's great he's an
awesome actor i want to see more of him
uh decent cash is some of the stuff is
kind of forgettable well as a little
also i think a lot of people's
complaints and mine included was that
the bryan cranston's storyline in him as
an actor character was more fascinating
we want to see more of him ya RAB so in
the splitters we'll talk a little more
of that but we want to see more of him
but this really is aaron taylor-johnson
if there was a main character it would
be him right he's fine i mean he's got
you know he's in the previous got he's
got a wife he's got a kid and he's
trying to get to I mean it's so it's
just basic something you know I mean
it's basic kind of disaster movie stuff
and he does a good job but yeah I just
think he need to do a little bit more
but I mean besides all that that's not
why you go see Godzilla look at the old
Godzilla movies Godzilla versus
Mechagodzilla godzilla vs. space gunsel
i mean these movies are not you know
deep you know things of you know theater
and our i mean this is just supposed to
be Godzilla I think your AdWords took it
to a level we haven't seen it done yet
especially keen to the last one oh yeah
yeah ooh and so my name is I mentioned
in my overall thoughts yeah there I do
appreciate the suspense but i think it
was overdone right there was just a lot
of times where they would just cut away
from a supposed action right and
sometimes it works you know sometimes it
like there was a couple shots where they
cut away from where like okay that was
cool right but then there was other ones
where they just kept on kept on just
showing like five seconds yes like
they're like about to fight they're
gonna fight but you don't get a seat
right yeah so i think that is something
that a lot of people had issue
with and I have to agree with them
because it's not like I need like all
this action is just that you can't just
do the suspense thing all the way
through i think i think if they had
maybe stopped it halfway and then gotten
more into like showing more godzilla i
would have been fine but they really
took it all the way to the end yeah they
do yeah they took it to about like the
movies about two hours long they don't
really get into it until about hour and
a half in yeah yeah that's true but I do
i do anyway this is analysis news now
they are doing a sequel yes been
announced I mean this movies made 93
million is projected it like I think 63
the studio's had really yeah they
projected 63 that have been good at blue
out of the wall they're just shocked
this like I did so well so you got
greenlit what sunday i think or so yeah
they were working on that stuff like way
before lime soda grim had to fight a
little bit it's still fighting it's not
quite green he has a script i think
almost finished I don't think it's quite
greenlit yeah yeah because they wanted
to see how gods are right here they
right now Godzilla do not only for a
pacific rim 2 but now Godzilla to right
they're probably gonna rush that into
production first before or they go to
pacific rim so right well probably do
godzilla to and probably release it but
yeah then do pacific rim I get monsters
back in the forefront of people's money
exactly yeah I mean I think this is
interesting why the findings in
machina's Godzilla domestically did
better than spider-man domestically I
know about international international
sales but domestically did better which
always makes you wonder you think I mean
cuz the last Godzilla came out and
didn't do that well it bomb um you think
this was a good quizzes of a good
trailer because of good buzz or you
think nobody's getting burned out our
superhero movies are making tons and
tons of money but you think people were
ready for something in fresh like Oh
Godzilla's not spider I think the
marketing campaign was smart and welcome
I think that's why I like with the
campaign of not showing too much
Godzilla I was cool yeah yeah for the
movie a little less over that marketing
it was kind of cool because then it's
like the suspense I want to see Godzilla
I want to see go ahead and and the
reason why it works is because it does
deliver
the design of Godzilla cool the action
sequences especially at the end were
right that's the thing that 1998
Godzilla did not do know the design did
not look cool he look like a hybrid of a
Jurassic Park dinosaur and like I just
had something to have like spikes on
here they had like little bit baby yeah
baby Godzilla no just like a velocity
yeah it was just silly yeah this
Godzilla is not silly no it's pretty
serious and that's where kind of a
little the problems I have because they
did want to take the serious route so
they want to have this story and you
know have actors acting serious and it
didn't quite work for me we're like okay
Pacific Rim we know like okay it's just
silly right yeah that's what's most
feeling it's silly we can let whatever
go this one the tone of it was no okay
we're gonna get realistic and so I
wanted a more compelling story whereas
with Pacific Rim I didn't need it
because that's not what they were going
for true I mean yeah I mean Karen with
del Toro came out and said this is
supposed to you know ignite your inner
10 and 11 year old supposed to but for
some reason this movie was more
compelling for me not because even on a
even from a fun factor I had more fun
watching this at the Pacific Rim even
though I do enjoy Pacific Rim I just
enjoyed this a little bit better some
reason this we even said when you saw it
you can say it now you see saw it you
know don't you guys he loved before it
came in at an advanced screening and you
when I i think i texted you that night
and I said well you know what did you
think of it you said you said some
people will love it yeah I think I'm
just one of those people III really
actually love this movie a lot I think
I'm yeah yeah I think you know with the
suspense I mean it is a slow-burning
yeah in like I said I do appreciate a
lot of that art aspect of it was just a
little too much plus you know they
should have just focused more on Brian
Krebs just making the main character and
done that all the way through versus you
know they want to get the young hero you
know the oh yeah I got kick ass young
action hero yeah yeah with the wife and
kid it's like yeah we don't know we're
seeing too much of that sorry exactly so
you know let's give our overall thoughts
in our grade I'm going to give
movie of be okay I think I do think it's
kind of a must see if you're interested
in is she a big screen Xfinity I yeah
tawny AMC Prime yep which was nice you
know like you want something with good
sound and a large screen just like yeah
we did our review for Pacific Rim I'm
sorry max we do that day yeah we you
want to see it large because you know
you're seeing something that's supposed
to be big right it's not meant to be
seen you'll go like some local indie
theater and so yeah I want to do that i
did not dissing indie theater all those
easy just that this is the type of movie
that you want to see in a big stream
great sound right yeah and I thought
visual effects were great and action was
great needed more of it and besides that
the story I think needed it needed work
there was like some plot stuff we'll
talk about in the spoiler section that
that was a little often that I think
could have made it more compelling but I
have faith that the sequel is gonna
deliver and improve and fix a lot of the
problems of this one okay I'm actually
gonna give it an a minus I really
enjoyed it like I said this hit my sweet
spot for some reason it's not perfect
there were definitely some flaws but I'm
excited for the sequel glad were that
they already green leather that's going
to happen they're going to get a script
don't I hope they see the flaws hear the
fans you know the fans are loud with
this is making good money but the fans
are speaking so hopefully they'll you
know change them things will probably
see I'm sure a lot more monsters not
gonna I don't think they'd hide
Godzilla's much the second know like
that's why I've been revealed so we're
gonna see more of him so yeah definitely
a minus and yeah good go see it in imax
3d for sure alright so let's get into
our spoiler section so if you haven't
seen the movie yet you can turn this off
and come back after you seen it so yeah
um one of the main issues is the bryan
cranston he dies and like in the very
beginning yeah i thought okay i had
heard that he wasn't going to be a main
character fine i thought that they were
going to take his character at least
through the whole journey that we were
see him sprinkled in throughout yeah
like helping out the military helping
out ken watanabe right helping out his
son Aaron
whoever's forgot the name of Aaron tail
044 help me cuz then also you know maybe
try and develop more of that relate as
well nah he dies in like 20 minutes
those the point even his wife you know
the I forgot her name she's been around
I mean she's good I know yeah she's good
actors I wanted to see I was like oh I
kind of like them it was too bad they
just kind of went out and Aaron
taylor-johnson he was he's not as
compelling as Bryan Cranston but i don't
know if that I don't think that's his
folks actually like him in the kick-ass
movies i think his dialogue his script
that he was giving just wasn't didn't
have anything interesting to do he was
just kind of this army guy who happened
to be in the right plays like oh hey I
can disarm that bomb yeah hey I'm here
exactly always survivor I can do that
and I'm laughing at this oh the these
monsters happen to be going to my
hometown my wife and kid are perfect
like it was is everything mate can I
help on barn yeah like I get right is
that cool okay as I cool yo my military
those guys like little gems like I'm
military oh of course come on come on
man come on we're all going mainland
like really oh so those are things kind
of bothered me I wanted you know I think
it was a mistake to make him the main
character or at least have Bryan
Cranston more heavily involved so that
they could have that father-son day hmm
good luck about this is stupid silly
thing about like worst school bus driver
ever the scene on the bridge every time
that but I was Florida's haha hidden
people I mean and that's the thing how
did Aaron taylor-johnson reunite with
his son and where they Candlestick Park
I don't know where they were somewhere
so yeah it was probably it's like just
with this kid all of a sudden my god it
works out Pac Bell Park yeah okay Paul
yeah oh they're dhokla that's right
there in Oakland that's gonna be one any
one of the right things I mean there
were some you know I guess you had to
kind of suspend you know yeah leaf a
little bit you know it's just this is a
movie it's a fantastic movie still weird
stuffs gonna happen but again like I
said I love this movie so it didn't
really distract me it kind of made me
chuckle while I was watching the movie
he can't watch it hobbie again under use
I mean I like he was kind of quirky
scientists discovering all this stuff
and just look at the charts like this
happened 15 years ago but I just wanted
to see him doom works I know he's
capable of so much more and so so
speaking of like we talked about early
or like the cutting away so the two
incidences that were I thought the
colorway was cool which one was like
when Godzilla is about to fight the the
male Muto in Hawaii and then they cut to
the the TV yeah the kid was what I
thought that was funny yeah I thought it
was funny because like dinosaurs mommy
yeah that's good and then the other time
was weaned elizabeth Olsen was running
into the bart station in play the doors
closed which is different from that the
trailer has different scenes in it so
the trailer the one of those teams was
that one where he had that long scream
during the truth she got oldest roaring
like facing the door and it shuts
another scene which is one we can talk
about now it's in the trailer I love is
the halo jump when they're jumping and
that's a cool cut away it's kind of a
cutaway cuz like when Aaron Taylor's
dropping and you can see the monsters
fighting a little bit any kind of goes
you know down past Godzilla's face like
I thought that was a cool that one makes
more sense I really did like that halo
jump a yellow really cool who's the
music from 2001 Space Odyssey it sounds
cool yeah but then you had other stuff
that was more where you would see them
finding the background right and then
but then they would just kind of move
back to the humans right or they'd be
like they have pan up and you see
Godzilla about to fight like there's one
scene at the end where he grabs the neck
of I think the male movie or the female
movie oh yeah and it ramms him to the
building like oh it's gonna get started
and then the cut cut away yeah then they
pan down or cut away to the humans yeah
it's like I don't really care about the
humans right Lorelei right but I did
like how they would like shroud Godzilla
so like in the rain you know and then at
night like I think this first time
Godzilla I kind of fell over was just
tired you to take a break you know I
like you know like when Aaron Aaron
taylor-johnson you forward and him make
contact they look at each other the eyes
and like this kind of smoke just yeah
that was cool also like when Godzilla's
tail lit up for the first time in the
comic I like yeah like it both both I
seen it twice not every time people clap
exactly who's that tech is it in the
trailers you don't see
no yeah they don't want to give that
away yeah I'd like when he Souza steal
it I was like yes he's gonna breathe you
know and I thought that was I love the
sound effects almost like a jet engine
when he was doing the fires not fire but
and of course we have to talk about the
let the last shot of the fight he opens
up the the female mucosal first Ryu
examine that remember King Kong Peter
Jackson King Kong had that badass fight
scene where he beats the t-rex he just
like opens inches but I was like and
then we did the fire you know breathe
and doing was like okay that's different
that's yeah first he was good you
thought they're gonna rip off that again
yeah and then he breezed the fire down
is that was awesome then that he was
carrying the head right yeah and then
gave out the Godzilla roar that was
badass so you know like all those fights
because you know the tail smacking the
the wings yeah male version into the
building the building topples over and
falls down on them so yeah I'm just you
know I just wish there was more of that
and I think in the sequel they're gonna
deliver on that I think so too yeah cuz
they're not gonna have to be like
they're not gonna have to do the
suspense mystery of Godzilla anymore
they're like we know what Godzilla is
like nobody looks like we know what he
can do now he's just gonna fight yeah
he's gonna have some she'll be different
types of monsters too I'm sure well I
know that they're trying to negotiate to
get the Mothra's in the row dance
because right now they don't have the
licenses for that and that's why they
created the moutain right yeah they had
to make something up mmhmm yeah so I'm
excited for the Seco I'm looking forward
to it okay yeah so let us know what you
thought you can post your comments below
on the website pink hero.com or on our
youtube channel think hero pro and make
sure to subscribe to that you also can
find us on twitter adenosine myself for
both that think hero i'm at griffin de
and we have a facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and share our
videos on twitter and facebook and other
social media
you